hey everyone my name is Astrid and
thanks in advance everyone to joining
this presentation and listening and also
thank you lab roots for the opportunity
to speak here so as I said my name is
Astrid I'm the founding manager and
managing director of outside technology
we provide expanded live results for
research and development and I'm going
to talk today about the generation of
expanded primary delivery results so as
you can see on the slides the content
that's going to be the solution of
outside technology the technology itself
and generally what we offer a prehistory
of the cells and the publications and
I'm gonna dive deeper into the actual
science of the hepatocytes deliver
sinusoidal energy via cells and other
cell types we provide for our MD so what
we're trying to offer is we're trying to
find the best cellular model on the
market so as you all know for
hepatocytes for example on one side you
have this alliance that's have g2 or
hyper G they come with a high
availability so they proliferate you can
use them for screamin applications and
on the other side you have the primary
hepatocytes which have a higher
physiological relevance but sometimes
the tissue is hard to get or they lot
sizes are quite small so we're aiming
for a compromise model meaning we're
trying to offer a cellular model which
has on the one side high availability
and on the other side has high if it's
physiological relevance so this is a
more holistic approach so that suitable
for cells that in general do not
proliferate in vitro such as the
hepatocytes or where the tissue is hard
to get or in general where we have low
sell yields or also if you have a
patient direct material where you just
get a few hundred thousand cells for
example so how do we do that
here you see a brief overview so we
either isolate the cells on our own or
we buy them from commercial vendors or
we also do have a network of university
partners
we get the prior results from so we
usually work with adherence also we take
the cells either fresh or crime
preserved we thought assaults we put
them into a plate and we have a genetic
library of different genes and gene
combinations which we try out so we
using lnter l2 inspection so we
genetically modifying the primary
results usually we do that in a six-mile
plate where we try out different genes
and gene combinations as I said but also
different media supplements and we
transduce the salts and then we wait for
the hepatocyte that process of the salts
to start to proliferate can take up to
several weeks it's easier for salts for
example for keratinocytes keratinocytes
skin cells that already do proliferate
so at some point the cells start to
proliferate and we can expand the cells
in house and of course we want to check
if they are still liver cells so we do a
quality control we check for the
prototypical liver markers I come that
to that later and I'm in the
presentation and it's really important
to mention that these cells are not
fully immortalized so we're not
generating a saline it's a little bit
dependent on the donor as well as the
cell types how far the cells proliferate
so for example for keratinocytes the
skin cells as I said they do proliferate
up to 60 or 70 population that links for
the liver cells who are focused on that
presentation they do proliferate up to
30 or 35 population doubles so as soon
as we check if we actually still have
liver salts we do a production further
expand them and at the end we're selling
the cells ready to use I come to that
production theme again in two slides so
as an example here you have hepatocytes
there are two different donors so you
see one donor at the bottom and one
donor on the top so we see the cells as
you can see on the left side sub
confluent meaning they still have space
on the plate to proliferate so the left
side is still showing a premie however
when hepatocyte directly after sitting
then we do the genetic modification we
take the lentils put it in the
supernatant on the soles and transduce
the cells and after some days or weeks
you can see little islands of cells
growing out of the well or basically out
of the cells and then we do a first
passage of the cells so that's the
crucial step as when they survive the
first passage you can use you can treat
the cells that so you would treat normal
cell lines on the right side you see as
soon as the cells actually hit
confluence they are contact inhibited
and they start to differentiate so we do
have a weekend friendly protocol so
there it's also slightly differently
treated than priming hepatocytes your
thought assault you give them a recovery
phase and then you can start using them
for your experiments on the bottom you
see a different donor the primary cells
directly after seeding look really nice
and fit but after the lent about
construction you can see there there has
been a contamination with other cells so
the primary hepatocyte or the islands of
primary have had a site so surrounded by
fibroblasts and if the that's basically
to show if the donor is not pure it
makes our life really hard because we
upside everything all the cells which
are in the well and we have further
purification steps where we try to
really just isolate the hepatocytes but
it's just in general to show the pure
the donor the bed of glass if your
experience with the different donor so
we have different donors available you
can also see that the morphology of the
differentiated cells it's different and
it can really yeah see which donor you
are working with if you experience with
the different donors so as i said before
i said that i'm gonna explain the the
protection scheme again so as i said we
start with the up siding we
general restart we can start with a few
hundred thousand cells but it's
preferably to have more like five or ten
million or basically a vial of priming
hepatocytes we upside the cells we
expand them we freeze back up in between
and we try to expand them to a master
solving and we're already checking
initially from typical hype adam hype
attic markers to prove that these cells
are still hepatocytes we freeze down the
master solving which is typically ten
miles consisting out of around 10
million cells with the population
leveling up around 15 and from there we
can expand further to working cell bank
which we then sell ready to use so as I
set the cells are not fully immortalized
we expand them in-house and provide them
cry preserved ready to use with for
example our protocols which you can then
can follow for the different experiments
with that production we can generate up
to 3,000 miles from the same donor so
that is way more than you can achieve
with just a typical premier hepatocyte
isolation so the advantages of the
technology are that as I said you can
create up to 3,000 Wells from a single
donor which makes them suitable for
example screening applications they do
have the primary cell features so we
always start with healthy human cells so
they not i'm generated from a cancer or
they're not a cancer cell line the
character blake is stable and they have
a physiological relevant profile and
usually the cell type-specific specific
phenotype the even size channel so if
you experience in general with premier
parasite that should not be a problem
from the handling site they're more
comparable to a saline we have protocols
for use which will provide we have
detailed information on each donor and
also they come along with optimized
media we do four they have parasites and
the other liver cells we have different
donors available and we also do custom
up sighting of primates
that come to them in the second as well
and you can basically use the cells for
everything use the primary cells for so
they are flexible and use you can do for
example 2d or 3d cultures or co-culture
with other cell types one highlight to
mention is here that they actually
survive in cultures and have stable
metabolism up to four weeks that is an
advantage over the primary cells as well
because usually the primary hypothesised
the differentiy quite fast in culture so
as a summary as I said what we offer we
are on one side we have there ready to
use cells they come in five million
cells ok cry while we also do have a
license model if you want to expand your
own come along with cell culture media
which is specially designed for our
cells but you can also use Prime results
so we had to have a lot of customers who
are actually using primary hepatocytes
but using our media well the upside
service that comes in handy when you for
example have a specific cell type or you
have a favorite donor usually the pharma
companies have a favorite donor when it
comes to a podocytes
or when you have patient-derived disease
material that's a flexible milestone
dependent offer we can do a basic
characterization of the cells we can do
like an extensively characterization of
the cells we can expand the cells and do
further customization for example we had
a really nice project last year where we
had a knockout Mouse and we isolated the
hepatocytes from that Mouse and outside
the cells and they still have that
knockout after up siding so that
scientists can keep continue working
with the liver cells of the mouth
without having to kill a mouse every one
every second week so if you go into
apartment we have quite some
publications available that's
specifically for the up side parasites
in regard to toxicity testing but also
to transporters or for example
metabolism so the list is available on
the homepage
but also yeah just go into PubMed and
type upside in there now I come to the
scientific part of the presentation so
for the hepatocytes as you all know
their current problems of the hepatocyte
model so on one side you have the
primary hypothesis they might be limited
in lot sizes and availability in general
you have huge donor differences so and
also within the lot you have a great
variability so it's kind of time
consuming to qualify each block again
and usually the culture is limited to
some days if you have a monoculture if
you do Co cultures they can survive for
longer but they're also d different
shape in culture on the other side you
have the tumor cells for example have
our G hep t2 which are great cell models
it's also always dependent on what
you're looking for and what your output
of the experiments are but here they you
don't have a donor choice they are
cancer derived and sometimes for example
for hyper G it's a mixture of two cell
types and you'll also need a high
concentration of DMS out in the media to
actually differentiate themselves
you also have IPS derived cells I think
in my opinion that works quite well for
other cell types but it does not work
for liver derived to put aside so I pass
the rights and homicides the
differentiation state is still in an
embryonic stage so in my opinion this
doesn't work for have other sites when
you look at ourselves they're primarily
like phenotype them metabolically
competent they have stable metabolism
for weeks and culture we have data
showing that they are proliferating you
can also translate them and we have
different donors available we also have
one disease model which is an enzyme
defect which is not quite known but the
Wikipedia entry to haibach's ilaria is
great and you can basically use them for
everything you as a primary cells or the
cell lines for example cytotoxicity
genotoxicity need induction clearance
and for other applications
so how do we know that our souls are
still hepatocytes after we up cited them
so what we do in house is first of all
check for the mythology sort of the
difference in morphology from
hepatocytes to for example if I robust
is quite clear so as soon as they hit
conference they have the typical
cobblestone morphology and what we do
test in house is typical markers as for
example Saito carotene 1818 as well as
human serum albumin and if you let the
cells stay in the culture for longer
than five days they form biochemically
and that's all data which is published
and to basically show that our
hepatocyte are still liver derived what
we also do in house is recheck for the
enzyme activities so in house we do one
a two to be nine to see nine and three
or four as I said in the beginning it's
a compromise model so the activities are
not as great as when you have fresh
premier podocytes but they're on a
similar level then for example if you
compare them to a perigee so we're quite
good with for example sub three four
will not the cells don't have a great
one a two activity but we always working
on improving the upside process I'm a
quiet confident to show or increase the
activities for example a1 a2 within the
next year for the enzyme themselves so
we can induce the activities with
producto prototypical inducers for
example ramp is seen but we can also
inhibit with prototypical inhibitors the
phase two activities which you can see
on the bottom right there similar to
premier hepatocyte so they're really
well retained after the upsetting
process if you look at the transporters
that's actually a published paper from
marina england from 2018 on one side
they checked for the sinusoidal
transport us as well for the canaliculi
transporters and the experiments were
divided in three phases
was the mRNA expression the other ones
protein abundance and then actually the
active uptake of compounds so I'm the
sinusoidal side it does not look great
so we the transporters or if you compare
them to Prime we have other sites are
quite low and for example or T V 1 B 1
and B 3 are very low so they also show a
lack of active uptake of through those
transporters but the active uptake for
example for n CTP and to be 1 and OCT
one worked quite well on the canonical
decide the transporters are quite well
preserved so they comparable to the
primary hepatocytes one note here is
that they actually just tested three of
the eight donors which are currently
available and we don't really have data
of the transporters before up siding so
it could be that they were already quite
low on the OTP side for example and also
they did some media evaluation if you
take out next time it has on for example
from the media it improves the OTB one
performance so there's still a lot to
discover and a lot to play around with
the media composition for example the
culture conditions in general but that
applies to the transporters as well as
the metabolism part when you look at
toxicity testing I just put a summary
slide together here because we have
quite a few publications so we have
comparison to from the upset of
parasites to premium and hepatocytes but
also hefty to four different end points
as ATP MTS also 24 hours dosing as well
as one-week dosing in one paper a later
highlight is the first one from 2016 a
paper about long-term toxicity testing
so as I said one advantage of those
cells that you can actually culture them
quite long and that opens possibilities
which you don't have
with prime results so you can really do
repeatthedose toxicity testing up to
three weeks which you can't definitely
do with the primary cells
so in summary as a set for toxicity
testing we have quite a few data quite a
lot of data available also for example
called stasis apoptosis or stare ptosis
testing and since they do proliferate
you can also use them and gene talks for
example for the micronucleus a you can
also transfer the cells we have tested a
lot of transactional reagents in-house
for example barber my rat which we think
is a great one
we transduce the salts with gfp and so
on
you can use them for metal of metabolism
but i just presented for long term
clearance for example since they are
stable for so long in culture but also
in 3d culture so you can Co culture them
for example with the live liver
sinusoidal energy is also cooked results
you can use them in printing devices
steroid cultures for example the lower
judgment plates also fluidic liver chip
systems and put them on any different
scaffolds or matrices other experiments
or applications are for example insulin
dependent metabolic activity sa but also
you can use them for viral infection for
example we have data which is public
published for HTV all over it's as I
said from the beginning it's a
compromise model so from the functional
side they're quite good the main
advantages just to highlight them again
are handling and also the lot sizes and
also the long term culture so as an
alternative to preemie human hepatocytes
which is currently the gold standard it
depends a little bit on the application
you might want to use them for I don't
see it as a replacement for premier
podocytes i rather see it as a
complementary model to premier parasites
in a way better physiological model then
for exam
FG to the second part of my presentation
is actually about the Liveris sinusoidal
understand yourself so a lot of people
do work with paddle sides but not a lot
of people work with the other cell types
of the liver so the l6 are basically
part of the non parenchymal cells of the
liver and same for the coupe results or
the stellate cells and it's quite hard
to isolate them so if you have a little
piece of liver tissue you generally can
isolate milk isolate millions and
millions of hepato sites but just a few
hundred thousand of those and they do
not proliferate as well so the outsides
are lining the blood vessels within the
liver and the highly specialized cells
so they're scavenger endothelial within
the liver and to them we did basically
the same as we did to their paddle site
so we up cited them and they're quite
known for three main receptors so they
do have a high uptake with in the liver
and they also take up a lot of toxins
and transfer them to the hepatocyte so
the most common known liver specific
uptake receptors are the Munoz receptor
the scavenger receptor and cd32 B so as
I said we can generate we started with a
few hundred thousand cells of those and
we can generate up to several thousand
miles of the same donor as well and what
we did is we characterized them from
typical endothelial cell marker as well
as typical liver specific markers so
here you can see the morphology so the
cells are actually quite pretty
the typical endothelial cell markers are
for example CD 31 or 2 formation in
matrigel but it really proved that they
are delivered arrived we also take test
for the Munoz receptor or for example
the uptake of its evolved amine and we
stay in for life one which are more
liver specific markers so there's the
research has been limited to the lac
of primary cells or as I said in the
beginning they're quite hard to isolate
and if you go into PubMed you'll find a
lot a lot of publications about
hepatocytes but just a few ones about
the L sakes because yeah if you can't
really isolate the primary cells you
can't really do a lot of research on
them so if you were in the field of
toxicity testing a lot of people just
use the hepatocyte but kind of leave out
the other cell types of the liver but
they are quite important as well so
we're currently writing a publication
tricks to show that for specific
compounds the else eggs and they have
parasites at different sensitivities and
also when you use them in 3d culture the
toxicity or the toxic response to
different compounds is different than
when we just use the hepatocyte alone
also the quite important in the immune
response of the liver so for example IgG
a particles are taken up by the cd32
receptors and also they do play an
important role or antigen uptake an
antigen presentation within the liver so
there's definitely a lot more to
discover and yeah we're really hoping
that we can convince people who are
working with the podocytes also to look
at the other cell types of the liver
what we have done with a customer who's
or let's say a collaboration partner
they have a liver on a chip system they
called dynamic 42 and as you can see
they have a perfused liver Qi system
well they have an upper channel and a
lower channel and you can basically see
it on one side you can see the epochal
sites and on the other side you can see
it the l6 and they make the typical
space of dizzer within the liver and
what you can do is also include for
example blood derived monocytes which
represent the coupe results for example
into that chip and another option would
also be perfusing
T cells for the antigen presentation so
there are a lot of possibilities and
there's a lot of research currently
going on in regard to co-cultures and 3d
cultures and we're really thrilled to
see more so in summary what we offer we
have the upside the petal sides i've
been talking about we have the upside l
sex we have different donors available
we're also working on Cooper's cells but
to admit upsetting cells of the immune
system are quite tricky so we have a PhD
student who's also working on monocytes
and natural killer cells we also have
available keratinocytes for example or
micro vascular endothelial cells or
skeletal muscle cells and we currently
get a grant project to work on
enterocytes cells from the intestines as
well as adipocytes
which are basically the fat tissue as I
said at the very beginning we not only
offer the cells we also have media which
comes along with the cells was specially
designed for our up cells
up side cells but can also be used for
priming cells so if you have any further
questions feel free to write me an email
we are officially distributed bye bye
ivt worldwide so either you can send
them an email or me an email or call and
thank you for listening and yeah have a
great day